to start out this video i want to run a
little exercise with you
it's probably been a while since you
have watched anything from season 5 of
game of thrones but i want you to try to
think of a genuinely great moment from
the season
besides some of the main events that
happen later in the season like the ones
i'm showing on screen i'll give you a
second to try to think of one
[Music]
it's hard isn't it i've made a ton of
game of throne videos and i'm even
struggling trying to think of one myself
and i assume you know where i'm going
with this and that is
all the subplots within season 5 are
inherently dull and are mostly just
boring this is ironic given that for
season 4 the subplots were basically at
their peak
and i talked about that in the last
video but now the subplots are almost at
their worst for season five
so let's figure out why there was a
remarkable decline in quality for these
subplots
looking at john stone's stannis
baratheon subplot not much really
happens
there is barely any conflict that goes
on in the night's watch for these two
characters
this applies for stannis especially
because he acts like that weird uncle
that crashes on your couch for far too
long he stays at the night's watch for a
total of 5
episodes and the only thing he does is
ask jon stone to recruit the wildlings
and for john to join his army multiple
times by the way
kneel before me lay your sword at my
feet pledge me your service and you'll
rise again as jon
stark traitor who plunged a dagger in
rob stark's heart
don't you want to avenge him you want
the wildlings
to march in your army or you could see
if this torment fell as more willing to
compromise than manso was
but the best way to help the most people
might not be sitting in a frozen castle
at the edge of the world
this obviously becomes very repetitive
given that even after getting denied by
jon snow
he keeps asking to the point of where it
just gets awkward
how long you plan to stay at castle are
you bored of us already
he should have just left after episode
two but instead he awkwardly just stays
it's as if david and dan didn't know
what to do with stannis so they just
left him at the night's watch to run out
the clock on his eventual demise
what was once an interesting character
devolves into a more hollow shell
of what he once was feels bad man
for jon snow as well the conflict
throughout most of the beginning of the
season was pretty boring
like i really doubt that anyone wants to
watch him sign papers for this long
really his only conflict was jano's
slint disobeying his orders
besides that though he basically just
sits around running the night's watch
until things finally get more
interesting when he goes to hard home
so in that fact staying in the same
setting with very little conflict
hurt these two subplots immensely
for tyrion's journey at least we have
some visual and setting variety but
pairing him in sergio or mormont is very
lackluster
the dialogue between these two
characters just revolves around tyrion
saying something
and sir jorah getting mad at him or
giving a very minimal response
you think daenerys will execute me and
pardon you
i'd say the reverse is just as likely
this just ruins the strengths for tyrion
as a character because a part of what
makes him so engaging
is his rich dialogue a primary
similarity for this is tyrion's
traveling companion in season one
i should just take your food and leave
you here what would you do then
starve most likely the pairing of brawn
and tyrion made for a great duo of
comedy and witty dialogue that is mostly
missing with the pairing of sergiora in
season 5.
also i noticed a trend that started this
season which is tyrion constantly making
crude or demeaning jokes in front of
varys
and him responding with a disappointed
or annoyed reaction
this basically happens for the entirety
of their time together for their first
few episodes
this is where i think tyrion's initial
decline as an intellectual
character started because david and dan
have proven that they can't write
dialogue on the same caliber as george
rr martin
given that they kind of ran out of books
after the fourth season
a few other subplots that are dull that
i want to mention without going into
depth is jamie's subplot and having to
deal with the sand snakes
sansa getting tortured by ramsay
daenerys having to deal with the sons of
the harpy
and brain of tarth just sitting around
waiting for sansa to become a damsel in
distress
none of these subplots are anything
special the sand snakes were a bunch of
irritating tweens
and jaime despite failing and getting
captured still achieved his goal by just
asking the king of dorne for marcella
and him agreeing which in of itself was
anti-climactic
sansa getting tortured by ramsay feels
redundant given that we've already
experienced all that drama with theon
then for daenerys she has to deal with
an enemy that is basically an anonymous
organization
and the writers failed to come up with
any engaging conflict for that subplot
like does anyone really care about
trying to have a fair trial for a sons
of the harpy member
and drama ensuing from one of your
advisors disobeying your orders because
of that
but yeah things for that subplot really
only get interesting towards the end
for cersei it's hard to sympathize with
her in creating a lot of unnecessary
conflict
given that marjorie and tommen seemed
very happy together
for arya a lot of her training involved
her just sitting around and cleaning
so that was just a massive waste of
opportunity for potentially the coolest
subplot
overall all these subplots show a
significant downturn in both writing and
any meaningful or interesting conflict
to drive their narratives
going on to the second point we have a
forced character death for the sake of
action and shock value
this is a small issue for the season as
a whole but it signifies something much
greater that impacts the entire show
and because of that this point annoys me
the most
so david and dan the strongers of game
of thrones decided to kill star
barristan selmy who initially at this
point in the story for the books
was not supposed to die one of the main
issues with forcing his character death
here
is a ripple effect that impacts
daenerys's entire subplots
this ripple being that cerberus and
selmy could have had a major role to
play
in the mad queen arc for season 8. since
sir barristan acts as an anchor for
daenerys to see the good side in life
this would have made him have more of a
contribution to the story
if he were to have died in season 8 to
thus propel dany to an even more
catastrophic mental state
instead of missandei getting executed in
season 8 it would have made more sense
for sir barrison to take her place
instead
sir barristan is like a father figure
for daenerys and throwing his character
death in some meaningless scene for
season 5
is insulting and building on that
sentiment even more
if you were to remove this ambush scene
from season 5 the marine storyline would
not
change this ambush scene doesn't have
any lasting
impact besides sir barristan's death and
greyworm being
injured it's just a bunch of random
nobodies that come out of nowhere for
the sake of action
a main issue with this method of writing
is that it completely contrasts what
game of thrones used to be in its prior
seasons
in season 1 for example there is like
two action scenes and those two scenes
had a lot of build up and had
actual lasting impacts for the story
bronze saves tyrion in the climactic
trial by
combat and jaime confronts ned stark
from the consequences for lady catelyn
kidnapping tyrion
these scenes have meaning they are built
up to and what happens heavily affects
the story and its characters
for this sense of the heartbeat action
scene they only check off one of those
boxes due to them killing an important
character
so david and dan take an easy way out
for this action scene
instead of trying to write a scene that
checks off these three boxes like the
first season and a part of why the first
season didn't rely on
action was because the writing and
dialogue was so engaging
and since david and dan can't rely on
dialogue pre-written by george rr martin
anymore
they had to do something like this force
action scene to make the season more
interesting this is why i think this one
small aspect
is so insulting and also acts as one of
the first red flags for game of thrones
starting to lose its charm
so looking at the third reason i want to
go into more depth about the
deterioration of writing that is done by
david and dan
so one of the most important aspects of
good writing is for it to be purposeful
for it to have purpose it needs to build
the characters move the plot forward
and to build a world in which the
characters inhabit i'll show an example
for each one of these characteristics of
good writing that is violated in season
5.
so first let's look at character
development
i think the best example that breaks
this in season 5 is the development with
littlefinger
he actually has quite a bit of screen
time in season 5 but most of his actions
throughout the season
go against the intellect of his
character and he just becomes a dumb
scheming villain for the sake of
creating conflict
and the main example of this is a little
finger selling off sansa
to ramsay the reason why this is an
absolutely terrible idea
is that you don't want to alienate the
person that literally witnessed you
killing lysa aaron
you should be trying to get closer to
sansa and winter over
along with the veil instead of making a
random pact with roose bolton
the manus has made you one of the great
lords of westeros
yet here you are in the north
undermining them i gamble with your
position
i mean literally anyone should know that
the boltons are running on borrowed time
given that they don't have the backing
of the lannisters anymore the north
hates them
and stannis is also coming to attack
them as well although that didn't
necessarily
pan out but my point still stands so it
just seems like littlefinger makes a
very stupid decision that compromises
his character
and that decision also turns out to be
one of the main factors that leads to
his death
and it was seemingly all to create
unnecessary conflict in sansa's
storyline
also in the books sansa wasn't supposed
to go back to winterfell and marry
ramsay
so this is a change made by david and
dan probably because they didn't know
what to do with sansa
for the second aspect of good writing it
has to move the plot forward and set up
future conflicts
for this we have the scene between lady
olenna and the high sparrow
you are the few we are the many
and when the many stop fearing the few
so that final line you are the few and
we are the many implies a future
conflict that gets completely dropped in
season seven
and this happens because at the end of
season six when cersei blows up the
great sept
there are no ramifications for her
actions
in actuality there should have been a
massive revolution where the citizens of
king's landing took over the right keep
because as stated in season 5 you are
the few
we are the many so this makes some of
the build up in season 5 seem like a
waste of time
along with it not having proper payoff
later on
for the last aspect of good writing that
gets violated let's look at
world building to me
this is the most significant aspect
because game of thrones has a massive
fantasy world
that has so much depth and for this
point i have a big example which is the
complete
exemption of the brand storyline a part
of what makes brand's storyline so
interesting and powerful at this stage
in the story
is that he can travel to any point in
time he can effectively show us
any aspect of the world that is still a
mystery
they did this to a very small degree in
season six but imagine if that subplot
was extended throughout season five
we could have gotten more answers to the
world especially with answers regarding
the white walkers
but instead david and dan for some
reason cop out and don't even bother
including bran in season 5.
i don't want to play with you anymore
my only assumption for this is that
david and dan couldn't come up with a
good enough story
and just made a shortened version of his
journey in season six
but yeah overall for this point david
and dan show they aren't the best
writers given that they sacrifice
proper character development setting up
the plot and building the world
for the final reason as to why season 5
is so mediocre i want to go into a
couple unsatisfying conclusions for this
season
so for the first conclusion this one has
pissed off a lot of people
and that is the demise of stannis
baratheon
the actual ending of him getting killed
by bryn of tarth and losing the war
is fine but the overall build-up to that
conclusion made it very unsatisfying and
anti-climatic
this is mostly due to sanus not doing
anything for most of the season
as pointed out when i talked about the
doll subplots
however this directly affects his
conclusion because there's a complete
lack of any interesting or engaging
build up to lead to his demise
if you look at his defeat for king's
landing the build-up to that fight was
engaging and every dialogue
seen along the way with stannis made us
care more about his journey
stannis deciding to kill his brother
conspiring with the red priestess sees
black magic
his debates with davos and stannis
deciding to push on even after losing a
large portion of his fleet
are all examples of great build up to
his inevitable defeat
for season 5 however a lot of this
happens off screen
his army just leaves in the night the
storm crows rolled off last night
many deserted before dawn how many
nearly half melisandre eats out of there
without talking about it
lenny milasana was just seen riding out
of camp
and the weather if anything ended up
beating santa's which is just
stupid using weather as a plot device to
hinder a character's journey
is unsatisfying to watch unfold we want
to see someone genuinely lose a battle
instead of losing to snow we're on and
out of food we can't open the supply
line
until the snow clears that's like saying
there was a terrible storm at sea when
sanus was trying to attack king's
landing
and he lost most of his fleet it's just
bad writing
instead have the characters make genuine
mistakes
or have the other side outsmart them at
every turn
similar to tyrion blowing up the
blackwater this is close to what ramsay
did in his strategy since he led a
surprise attack against stannis
but at that point in the story it was
already too late and everyone knew that
stannis was going to lose
the only satisfying lead-up to stannis
demise was the death of shireen
through a true act of desperation he
decided to sacrifice his daughter to the
lord of lights in order to give himself
better
odds in the war but that was really the
only interesting scene
in santa's journey for season 5.
for a second conclusion that is pretty
unsatisfying we have the death of jon
snow
initially i really enjoyed this
conclusion when the show was airing
and i thought that the show was
returning to what season 1 did and had
the balls to kill one of the main
characters
but that wasn't really true because he's
kind of an integral character to the
overall story and then he ends up
getting resurrected literally two
episodes later this completely undercuts
the severity of what happens and looking
back at that conclusion
it feels as though it's just there for
shock value and to end the season on a
crazy cliffhanger
so after re-watch especially this ending
loses a lot of its weight
by the way i think the scene itself is
enjoyable given the heartbreaking
portrayal of
ali but it could have been much better
if david and dan gave us more scenes of
john and ali actually bonding together
besides ollie just being jon stewart
so yeah these were my four overall
points as to why i think season five of
game of thrones is pretty mediocre
it has dull subplots it has a forced
character death that essentially marks
the downfall of the show
it shows off how much worse steven and
dan's writing ability is
and this season has some pretty
unsatisfying conclusions
besides a few good ones like with cersei
this is also me primarily talking about
the flaws of the season
and there are some gems there like with
hard home
but anyways if you like this video
analyzing season 5
then i've made 2 prior videos on season
4 and 1.
the next season i'll most likely do will
be season 6 and then after that i'll
probably do season 7.
i hope you enjoyed the video and let me
know what you thought about season 5 of
game of thrones in the comments